hi I'm dawn from San Diego and right now
we're in the beautiful eful region of
Germany and the first highlight that
we're going to see is the Nurburgring
racetrack for which I shift my car in
nineteen ninety three RS America Porsche
to drive this track so why don't we go
out and have some fun on the track and
see what we can do
okay here we go
this is the best ride in the world it's
better than any roller coaster I've ever
been on any other thrill ride
it was so much fun so much of an
adrenaline rush I had to tell myself to
breathe a couple times as I went around
some corners cars were passing me I was
passing other cars it was just great
are we to elfs castle one of the top 15
castles in the world beautiful it's like
a fairytale castle something out of the
Brothers Grimm we just don't have this
stuff at home you got to come to Europe
for this we're in the treasure room of
eltz castle and I find this type of
thing amazing because it was made
hundreds of years ago we finished with
eltz castle now we're gonna go see what
else we can discover in the evil region
of Germany
or in Monreal now and I'd heard it was a
nice picturesque german town we have
timbre stone houses all around us and
they're just beautiful they're so well
taken care of it after a long day it's
time for dinner looking so the
traditional Tarte flambe enjoy your meal
thank you had a perfect day at the
Nurburgring eltz castle now a good meal
it's the perfect way to end the day
goodbye